don't come to wales
that's the message to millions of
english scottish and northern irish
people
living in high-risk areas first minister
mark drakeford
says the new measures are needed to stop
the virus spreading west
the prime minister has been received in
reply to my request
i have therefore asked for the necessary
work to be brought forward
which would allow for devolved powers to
be used
to prop to prevent people from traveling
into wales
from high prevalence areas of the united
kingdom
much of wales is already under local
restrictions
in real which in better times welcomes
huge numbers of tourists
local people were pleased with the new
regulations
i think a lot of this second wave we've
got might have been down to
the tories coming in from the hot spots
i've got family
in manchester in the hot spots and they
were coming up here so
even though i've got family there i
think it's a good thing yeah if you're
on lockdown you should be staying in
your own area
i can't understand why bodies johnson
has not said stop in your own area
i've got a young daughter that lives in
warrington
who comes up pretty regular to see us
um and now we can't see them so i'm not
gonna get to see my grandchildren and
in some ways it's a good thing because
we need to get control of it
there is certainly politics going on
here too
the welsh government says it was forced
to act after prime minister
boris johnson didn't make travel
guidance in covid hot spots like
liverpool where the virus is surging
mandatory
one of the things this pandemic has done
is reveal
and exacerbate the tensions between the
centre
westminster and the rest of the union
other nations as we're seeing in wales
again
are going their own way and it may be
that when the dust has settled
the forces of devolution are a catalyst
for further change at times
it's felt like the union may be coming
apart at the seams
nicholas sturgeon denies using her daily
briefing
as a platform to play the independence
card
but her handling of the pandemic has
bolstered the yes camp
scots planning on visiting blackpool
this weekend
have now been warned not to after nearly
200 cases north of the border
were linked to the town it's not
possible to be absolutely certain where
somebody
actually picked up the virus but
blackpool is being mentioned
in test and protect conversations far
more than
any other location outside of scotland
that is the view from scotland
but at this bed and breakfast in
blackpool they're taking no chances
or bookings some of the people that come
from scotland
are really irresponsible and they want
social distance
no matter how much you tell them and
so it's quite a worry for us because
like it's our town and we don't want the
infection here
great britain is now a patchwork of
different approaches to covid19
wales will bring its new measures into
force by the end of the week
but the uk has never appeared more
separated
alex rossi sky news north wales